[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans checkup le
magazine santé de la rédaction ce
mois-ci nous parlons des travaux pour
une nouvelle maternité au centre
hospitalier de Versailles un tiers des
patients sont 50tinoises une initiative
portée par les étudiants de la fac de
médecine de 50 ans en Yveline pour que
les enfants aient moins peur à l'hôpital
le portrait du N Montaine Elia 18 ans
une ado presque comme les autres elle
est trisomique et nous avons passé une
journée avec elle mais d'abord donc
cette question autour de la perte
d'autonomie et de la dépendance un
chiffre les plus de 60 ans représentent
en France 22 % de la population ils
seront un français sur trois d'ici 2050
des Français qui espèrent vivre
évidemment le plus longtemps possible
chez eux alors des entreprises innovent
et elle propose des bouquets de services
pour le maintien à domicile comme cette
plateforme blue Linea implantée à
hencour une initiative saluée par le
ministère des personnes
âgées une balance pour mesurer
l'évolution du poids et contrôler la
dénutrition un bracelet d'autonomie
équipé d'un système GPS pour suivre le
malade dans ses déplacements et éviter
notamment les fugues des personnes
atteint
d'Alzheimer la personne s'en va le
système déclenche une alarme locale et
sonore et ensuite on
transmet au système des aides soignants
l'information de la fugue au niveau du
table voici quelquesunes des solutions
mises en place par l'entreprise blue
Lina dont la plateforme est implantée à
hencour un dispositif de bouquet de
service pour garantir le maintien à
domicile des personnes dépendante salué
par la ministre délégée aux personnes
âgées nous sommes dans le champ du
mouvement de l'innovation et je dois
dire que je suis extrêmement heureuse en
particulier du concours entre
l'entreprise et les collectivités
territoriales ici qui ont su se mettre
en en cohérence et en
convergence avant une commercialisation
complète comptait 69 € par exemple par
mois pour ce bracelet d'autonomie dont
une prise en charge à hauteur de 40 %.
une expérimentation va être menée auprès
de 1500 foyers couvrant une large zone
entre Versailles Grand Parc jusqu'à
corbeille et sonne un tiers des foyers
seront
saintctinois les personnes sont en cours
de recrutement nous on parle pas de
personne on parle de foyer 1500 foyers
parce que souvent quand on met en place
ce genre de dispositif on permet de
protéger les patients d'assister les
soignants mais aussi d'accompagner les
aidants ce recrutement va se faire par
le biais des communes euh donc des CCS
des clics des Mayas des différentes
structures bien évidemment nous avons en
chef de fil l'IPS l'Institut de
promotion de la santé de trappe et puis
aussi gér handicap le dispositif est
opérationnel depuis le 2 avril quant au
gouvernement il lancera le 24 avril la
Silver économie une filière pour réunir
tous les métiers liés au secteur de la
perte
[Musique]
d'autonomie 1700 naissances enregistrées
en 2007 au centre hospitalier de
Versailles 2200 en 2012 et les demandes
ne sont pas satisfaites du coup une
nouvelle maternité va être construite
dotée de nouveaux services
explication le centre hospitalier de
Versailles poursuit sa phase de grands
travaux après les urgences est a tour de
la maternité d'être repensé la première
pierre de l'extension vient d'être posée
elle comprendra des lit supplémentaires
une réalité chiffrée 1700 naissence
réalisé en 2007 2200 en 2012 là le
service va permettre d'assurer 2500
accouchements par an c'est un projet
porté depuis 10 ans euh il faut savoir
qu'il y a environ 8000 naissances dans
le bassin de population que actuellement
nous n'en faisons qu'un/art c'està-dire
que les 3/4 des patientes sont vont en
clinique privée ou si elles veulent un
service public sont obligés de quitter
le département donc il y a une
insuffisance notable ce bâtiment
s'accompagnera de deux nouveaux services
la néonatalogie et la
saintigraphie dans les evenings Sud nous
n'avons pas de service de néonat donc là
nous allons ouvrir 18 lits de
néonathologie et enfin la
saintigraphie avec l'arrivée
d'un d'un matériel
révolutionnaire qui s'appelle le T scan
c'est un du matériel d'imagerie qui
permet en fait de voir des pathologies
qu'on peut qu'on ne peut pas voir
ailleurs et en
particulier pour tout ce qui est la
cancér
l'ouverture de ce nouveau bâtiment est
prévu dans 2 ans pour un coût de 27
millions d'euros le centre hospitalier
de Versailles a sur parant 42000 séjours
d'hospitalisation et un/ers des patients
reçus sont
[Musique]
5tinois l'hôpital des nonounours une
belle opération portée vous allez voir
dans quelques instants par des étudiants
de médecine pour rassurer les enfants et
le éviter la peur de la blouse blanche
rencontre avec Léa et
Oscar léa a 5 ans elle est venu avec
Oscar qu'est-ce qu'on lui a fait à Oscar
on lui a donné des
médicaments l'a
opéré première étape la consultation par
le médecin et commeement il va prendre
du STOPO
d'accord médicament pour arrêter
d' la et Oscar passent ensuite dans la
salle de soin
un bandage autour de la tête du nounours
direction la radiographie pour voir ce
qu'il y a dans le ventre d'Oscar
oscar a mangé une sucette et le bâton
avec il faut donc
l'opérer direction le bloc blous
charlotte sur la tête masque sur le
visage léa est
prête anesthésie pince coton perfusion
tout est réaliste un hôpital des
nounours pour les 5 7 ans proposé par
poem une association qui regroupe des
étudiants de la faculté de mcine de 50
ans en Yveline l'objectif dédramatiser
le passage par l'hôpital et l'effet
blouse blanche sur des enfants pour qui
c'est souvent un univers inconnu il faut
vraiment tout leur expliquer et leur
expliquer que ils auront pas mal ou
alors qu'ils vont
sentir un petit pic ou quelque chose
mais expliquer ce qu'ils vont ressentir
pour pas que ce soit l'inconnu en fait
je pense qu'ils ont plus peur de
l'inconnu que que que les soins qu'on
leur fait cette initiative est née il y
a maintenant 10 ans d'abord développée
en Allemagne une pratique qui rassure
aussi les parents je pense que ça a
dédramatisé un petit peu le côté
hospitalier ça leur apprend aussi bah
comment ça marche une radio comment ça
marche quand on arrive à l'hôpital non
c'est c'est très très bien l'an passé 35
facultés de médecine à travers la France
ont participer à cette initiative 3000
étudiants volontaires qui ont reçu
quelques 10000
[Musique]
enfants le 21 marsit la journée mondiale
de sensibilisation à la trisomie 21 ela
à 18 ans elle est tiny Montaine c'est
une ado presque comme les autres qui
multiplie les activité nous l'avons
rencontré tout un mercredi c'est le
portrait du
mois il est 12h30 ce mercredi ela 18 ans
quitte les locaux de l'external
médicalisé de trappe pour rentrer chez
elle à Montini la jeune fille est
atteinte de trisomie 21 autonome Elia va
emprunter deux lignes de bus différentes
une passagère comme les autres c'est
d'ailleurs comme les autres que l'a
élevé Laurence sa maman
et là on a je tenais à la fois à ce que
elle est le maximum de confort et sa vie
la plus semblable de celle des autres
jeunes de son âge donc on a vraiment
beaucoup invité d'enfants et à la fois
lui apprendre voilà à à nous quitter
donc très jeune elle a été encolé une
vacances donc on a essayé de ne pas
l'enfermer dans lehandicap mais l'ouvrir
au monde aussi bien pour elle mais aussi
pour les autres c'est ton doudou ell a
un téléphone portable dispose d'une
boîte ma avec laquelle elle peut
discuter avec ses copines et dans sa
chambre comme toutes les adolescentes il
y a des posters de ses chanteurs
préférés
c'est
Anana tu préféré ah oui et aussi le riz
et si c'est c'est Gom il y a aussi jifer
Lopez Elia aime particulièrement le
maquillage j notre journaliste est
l'objet de toutes ses attentionsia est
aussi très
coquette regardes couleur il son
c le rose le rose
C
et les Verts et c'est pour ton amoureux
tu es un amoureux oui c'est çappelle
s'appelle tristtin il le sait oui
oh
la jeune fille a aussi posé récemment
pour une photographe Mélanie Garnier les
clichés ont été présentés au
conservatoire des arts de
montinia est très très épanouie sans
inhibition une grande joie de
vivre une facilité de contact qui est
quand même très agréable pour les gens
donc un regard toujours très très
positif ce qui fait que elle est vite
acceptée par par les jeunes et par les
adultes le CIRC le théâtre et multiplie
les activités il est 18h la jeune fille
rejoint son cours de danse africaine une
discipline qu'elle pratique depuis l'âge
de 6 ans toujours au milieu des
autresia fait
partie des enfants je veux dire meneurs
parce que du coup par par rapport à son
handicap elle s'en fiche un peu de tout
le monde moi au niveau pédagogie ça m'a
ça a été formateur quoi on l' canalisé
qu voilà pour la canaliser trouver les
outils qui allaient permettre
bah de de faire en sorte qu'elle se
concentre jusqu'à la fin du cours B du
coup je le vois plus du tout en fait son
handicap malgré l'éducation qui lui a
été prodiguée Laurence sa maman n'est
pas naïve elle mesure les difficultés
qu'il reste à parcourir pour une
intégration notamment
professionnel les préjugés que les gens
ont pu avoir à son égard c'est jamais
face à elle puisque un préjugé c'est
quand on ne connaî pas donc on n pas eu
à faire enfin elle a pas eu à faire
directement à à à ce type de préjugé
dans notre parcours on est
souvent voilà confronté à des gens qui
ne connaissent pas et quand on ne
connaît pas on a peur et qu'est-ce que
tu fais alors avec ton téléphone la
trisomie 21 est la première déficience
intellectuelle d'origine génétique une
conception sur 700 est concerné
aujourd'hui il existe un diagnostic
prénatal dans 96% des cas les parents
décident d'un avortement médical pour
les autres le regard est parfois lourd
ortter d'où cette 2è journée
internationale de sensibilisation et
d'information
[Musique]
oui ce nouveau numéro de checkup est
presque terminé allez avant de nous
quitter on va jeter un coup d'œil sur
l'agenda santé du mois le 12 avril une
formation au premier secours proposé à
l'Institut de promotion de la santé
c'estette attrape le 13 avril au prisme
à hencour un gala organisé par France
Alzheimer pour collecter des fonds au
profit de la maladie et puis le don du
sang je vous le dis tous les mois vous
le savez c'est une nécessité il y a des
collectes mobiles qui sont régulièrement
organisés comme le 12 avril à Versailles
le 14 avril à Saint-Rémi des chevreuses
ou encore le 26 avril à trappe checkup
c'est fini je vous donne rendez-vous le
3 mai pour un nouveau numéro du magazine
santé d'ici là portez-vous
[Musique]
bien